yo it's real 92.3 benadryl after-party
bootleg cab Drayson nitrous DJ damage my
first week here y'all so you know how to
bring out the homies man where you come
in please
God you got my brother in the building
man mr. Taylor Gang himself your hand
make a with Khalifa decide what I wear
so guys what's up ransom
so with I noticed you uh yeah yeah okay
we're gonna do that was going to smoke
on the ring well you know you know what
I was gonna find is the other day who's
going to be the first artist to sparkin
only two people came to mind because two
arts was gonna do it so you're gonna be
snoop
okay with and what happens to that you
got to do where's my weight right what
happens if the sprinklers come on and
take us out I don't think the sprinklers
is gonna come on because it's very much
electricity if that's not safe very
don't want to ruin that clothes in the
cons like that's what I do that goes
along with do with the [ __ ] you want to
do you just way out ops 100% man yo you
you'd been doing what you wanted you got
this new game man this Wizards weed farm
game yeah I installed it and I've been
playing it been growing my crops getting
my coins up oh yeah you got I know I
think I let's see let's see I think I
got like you got a harvester and then
they get the money down mm-hmm so you
got the whole operation on the new ass
oh yeah that's so smart
man I've never been thought about that
like the reception in the app been
really good um it got really dull
Brandon is online and all the fans that
that [ __ ] with it they've been hitting
me up cuz I try to stay interactive on
Twitter and [ __ ] yeah just asking them
you know keep checking in and they tell
me good things about it yeah dad like
doing man house bash bash is really good
there you go he's super big he's huge
and he just keeps me on my toes every
day what has been the biggest challenge
like obviously you're on the road a lot
you move around a lot but what's the
biggest challenge about being Wiz
Khalifa and having to raise a little man
at the same time I would say the biggest
challenge is not spending every moment
with him right you know I want to be
there with him all the time
but unfortunately I got a do you know my
work I got to travel I got to be healthy
so I need to sleep some time ago saying
it's hard to tell him like nah man I
can't play for two hours I got to lay it
down
but in any
and he's gonna respect me and no you
know was good right now I ain't [ __ ]
with it
speaking about respect you know as
fathers we know kids say two crazy
things gotta get older man crazy what
some things you know bad [ __ ] thrown at
you that caught you off guard a little
bit um the cuss words
oh man yeah straight up I'm up man yeah
yeah I thought it was gonna be funny he
wouldn't touch that I almost hurt you
you're like oh yeah
whoa whoa whoa who's this first cuss
word uh damn that okay that one wasn't
bad that one you give me I let him say
damn yeah you know we was in lowrider
thank you I get it yeah I mean but yeah
he's trying to watch your mouth around
him rap you know everybody who's around
trying you know what yeah that's my
problem because I'm super hypocritical
because I'll cut in front of him and
he'll be like oh don't say that I'm uh
I'm gonna smack your butt I feel like
I've allowed to cuss not you yeah we
were just talking before the mics came
on man you know we were waiting for
album from you for a minute
obviously been keeping us fed with you
know the Tanner game project but but
rolling papers - man let's talk about
that [ __ ] I've been I've been working on
that album for like I think like three
years now and on just develop a
different selves and going through
different things personally and really
trying to communicate that to my fans as
the next step of my life is the most
important thing for this album I'm not
really concerned with like making the
biggest craziest song I mean of course
the songs are going to reach huge
audience of course but as long as I feel
comfortable with myself and how I'm
projected you know my energy and my
words and my message and that's been the
whole thing and getting everything
together because I've been all over the
place I've done the soundtracks I'm
constantly doing features I'm constantly
working with my artists but to say that
this is my project to get to the world I
haven't done that in a long time and I
feel like this is a really important
project for me as well so I've taken my
time I've
out of the music and now I'm ready to
put it out you said - it might be a
double album right yeah yeah good
possibly be a double album I just want
the experience for the fans to be 100% I
don't want to just short them with you
know one thing or what they're used to I
always try to switch it up and do it
different and every you know great
artist is dropped a double album pot you
know The Diplomats album double out we
can do it you know what we can't do come
on war you know exactly bones I was just
saying that jay-z did the blueprint -
like you did what I'm saying so I feel
like we all as as legendary artists
reached that point where our catalog and
our fan base go like this really you
could drop that double out you know um
you know you were talking about kind of
like you you kind of have been doing so
much stuff but it's not yours and I feel
like you've been going through so much
in the public eye whether it's being a
father that you really haven't really
maybe expressed that as much as you know
fans of maybe one and you too through
music so are we going to get like kind
of let her take on you on what's been
going on in life early man I heard a
record man will play do something they
know like this might be the intro I
think was called [ __ ] or some [ __ ]
it's the whole record but I but she was
talking he was talking about you know
some [ __ ] that I'm sure a lot of fans
wanted to hear you know you know me I
don't really talk a lot like when it
comes to me I know I express myself
through my music and to be able to have
an album and that be my outlet to
express myself I'm gonna take full
advantage of that for sure
straight up man yeah uh I know currency
was on the first appearances always
gonna house is my one of my favorite
with songs off of spinner man she'll be
on the new practice yeah yeah yeah yeah
so else who else could be on the project
Chevy's going to be on the word Chevy of
course now I got a bunch of people and
it's crazy because all the production
and everybody that I work with I
considered him like in else because all
my home you doing friends but they're
really features and [ __ ] like that so
it's hard to like oh I got thunder
cattle now okay here's one I did a
channel Mike Dean a time
really yeah I worked with Alchemist on
this out you guys with all tomorrow yeah
that's what I would hear you they know
is like of course we love you we also
love the team around you I know um a lot
of us got excited including me when
we've seen that Taylor Gang ten going
easy mm-hmm not literally that that
happened to not be a thing but who are
some new artists may be on telly game
that you got in the pipeline's of people
you're pushing as a new faces to the
brand um really Taylor Gang is just all
about like you said the brand yeah so
when it comes to like our artists and
who comes out it's just whoever fans and
people are gravitating towards at that
time tires on Taylor Gang as well yeah
he's constantly played [ __ ] out and read
again you know what I'm saying so it's
hard for me because I oh yeah we got
tired next we got it cuz times always
blessing it is my working you know what
I'm saying it's the same thing with
burner you know what I mean it's the
same thing with Raven juicy any new
faces anybody new something fresh oh man
not we working on so we working with
y'all got it really quick kinda silly
you working on some crazy [ __ ] and [ __ ]
that Betty maybe you can tell me the
artists but what you key to me city they
wrap it pink smart okay we work yes
pecan Accardo man you just celebrate the
anniversary of cushion orange juice man
yes such a classic project how do you
celebrate that is there anything like
y'all bump in for the day y'all y'all is
just some unreleased track like you do
to celebrate that David we kind of
changed your life when it's got super
high um guy I got on I jumped I call
Cardo and recorded over some Cardo beast
at night cardones also on the album a
lot of people are gonna be happy to see
me and him working together in a minute
and uh you know plating that sound back
out there but like really it was just
work you know what I mean and like
that's what that's that's all I'm kind
of really into right now is just you
know trying to develop this new sound
and get people's attention focus on
other things now really
is one or two but just to widen their
attention span and kind of you know just
experiment and experience other things
yeah I know card oh and and the tailors
there was like a split for a while yeah
what happened I'm [ __ ] sorry the tail
again like two like at the end of the
day people associated our sound and
course you know the same thing so it was
like when it came time for us to put the
paper work down he was more on some Oh
what am I going to get out of the deal
as opposed to look what do I bring to
the table and I don't [ __ ] with people
like that like you know saying you could
be as talented as you want to but I'm
not going to deal with nobody's ego and
I'm not going to deal with anybody's
personality that's hard to deal with
because I'm a [ __ ] superstar and I'm
very easy to deal with so when it came
down to that I was like oh you don't
have to be we don't have to work
together so as soon as he got over his
egos like all right let's work together
he's not signed to us right now but I
don't mind making music with right
because he got over and the fans want
that man I want that yeah but I don't
want somebody who's going to be a dick
right you know I'm saying God get over
yourself I'm not hard to work with and
especially that early in the game where
it was like we're all still working and
grinding and have potential to do great
things you're gonna be great on your own
or you could be great with what people
want you to be doing you know what I'm
saying it's all up to you cuz I'm gonna
be I - you know I'm saying now does that
happen a lot because I know we spoke and
if you're a while ago and you're saying
how we was first starting telling gang
you were bringing people under your wing
you was doing things for them in you
know no contract signs out of the
kindness of your heart and they wouldn't
make that you know decision mm-hmm does
that happen to you a lot because a lot
of our gets thinking a lot of people get
entitled a lot of people see what I do I
make it look effortless and they want to
do the same thing and they don't want to
put in that work so you got to let
people fall flat on their face and
realize how good they had it and then
they'll come back to you and say I'm a
good dude so I never [ __ ] it on anybody
in my life so anybody who was my friend
can always come back and say you know
blah blah blah [ __ ] up this that
another thing it will be straight but I
don't deal with people's bad attitudes
at all like if you're ungrateful and you
feel like I'm not
or nothing for you then you can roll you
know you don't got to be around me I
don't got to be around you we don't got
to get no money together and that could
be that and then you know personally
[ __ ] we really got [ __ ] to say to each
other like I keep it I keep it really
simple you know what I mean because a
lot of I do business with my friends and
that's the most scary and the most
difficult thing to [ __ ] do so rather
than fall out and all of that [ __ ] I
rather just cut it short and then you
know go be great talk about the little
Lucy situation obviously there was like
a lot of confusion um because you put
the good chain on him I know he's music
I know y'all are boys yeah yeah I know
he down with sailor guy with drama
okay so he is with him yeah who's ezel
Taylor hey see what Taylor Gang has a
label and a management company okay so
we take on artists and we we help their
careers so it's like at the end of the
day when you're working with somebody
and you have different companies it
might not be Taylor Gang records yeah
but it's all Taylor Gang so change alone
pretty much goes down he has a whole
squad of people who's been putting his
career together right since before we've
been working with him doing business but
we've all been working together we've
all been on tour together we've all
shared the same space and got money
together so it only made sense for our
teams to merge that's what it really is
it's a merging of two sides I got had us
working together you know what I mean I
feel like when you took him on the boys
the summer tours I pronounced it that I
was like that was a changing point you
know I'm saying after like oh yeah I
seem to perform before that and after
that and I feel like once he came back
he had another confidence as far as
going in from everybody that went on
tour with me came back okay start with
Kendrick let's roll all the way to Big
Sean right everybody I've been on tour
while all of these dudes during the
summer it was the great summer tours and
then they've gone gone on I have awesome
careers and become you know headliners
and do festivals and things like that
that's that's how it's supposed to be 40
percent yeah you know so dramas a great
businessman of course you know I got
great business people with me shout out
the will shout out the constant shout
out everybody who
they do behind the scenes and on yeah
they put it together so it's Taylor Gang
in in a bunch of all of you mentioned
Kendrick man what do you think of that
damn album it's kind of like I love it
taking over hip hop yeah I love it I
love it because people you know they
support it you know what I mean and when
when everybody gets behind somebody and
cheers them on I'm always happy for that
person man
oh you kyndra Guster gets a lot of love
what else you listening to man how you
always I feel like every time I'm around
to the curve or ahead of this area
always hard liquor first about this guy
he was up on Makonnen so Perry like this
certain rappers like like how do you
find this [ __ ] I'm not talking about she
oh boy this [ __ ] man no more dog I'll be
on the internet like 24/7 man is kind of
scary you know you always on your [ __ ]
I'll tell you that yes you know what is
the most memorable Wiz Khalifa party
you've ever done because I I always we
had love do you remember that time was
in Flagstaff your cousin was there and
we just rode up to a frat party it was
like in the mountains and we just took
over somebody's house oh oh oh oh yeah
we were just standing there like in the
middle of the crib in the middle of the
Crean I was ratcheted we shouldn't have
done that
we just took over like literally a
little some pretty wild things man like
we taken over some bars and like New
Zealand he showed up pretty legendary
recently we went to this little spot and
got a model of nice it's called like
cafe no se and uh their rule is like you
got to get [ __ ] up like you got to
just have to get hammered so that was
pretty cool
uh Vegas anytime like my first buy real
pool party at the Palms I remember that
was I did way too much that night I
think I've probably done more douchebag
[ __ ] in my life at wizards like oh yeah
cuz we Carlton we kind of encourage that
commander I passed out on the couch in
fetal position I hate to wake you up you
had to wake the other one this was
recently I've buried a
definitely cap down because that's my
man right okay so what happens is when
you're at parties you notice me is what
what you when you sleep so this [ __ ]
fell asleep in the middle of the parties
are I'm talking about my [ __ ] was like
brown anyone something to keep us like a
baby I was like yo cab get up you go
over here as I go upstairs [ __ ] now I
get up right now he's looking at me like
ain't nothing where he was that you know
you got the first single picked out for
the new project today yep I got two
singles picked out um I actually got
three or four like um I'm gonna give
away my secret already um we're gonna
put out some songs and let people choose
okay just because of how popular
streaming is yeah you can check the
Spotify number exactly and that's what
we really want to do we want it to heat
up on its own everything's on demand
right right and then just let that
decider dictate you know and I mean like
people will gravitate towards what they
want so we're gonna put out some things
and like I said in different ways and
just try to figure out like make it
exciting for the fans and make it make
sense so you know yeah with these songs
right so you have three different songs
already different vibe okay so you can
really choose which way right right
it'll be it'll be different vibes it'll
be different just different ways to
approach things it's like people expect
certain [ __ ] from me because you got
Christian orange juice please
you got cabin fever with you you got
[ __ ] see you again Wiz I can't
abandon any of those dudes like pushing
me orange juice got me to where I'm at
right no cabin fever accused me in the
streets see you against one of the
biggest songs of all time - you got two
billion views on YouTube right I'm the
only [ __ ] with two or a light I think I
don't know this is I got a I don't know
it I gotta go through the numbers again
cuz they told me this is on yet no I
feel like this I [ __ ] love that song
got songs before oh my god maybe what I
found out so many it reaches so many
crowds and so many people and to be a
rapper and Adidas early in my career and
had that type of achievement I got an
embrace that and I gotta capitalize on
and do
or more like I don't have to make
another see you again but I deserve to
at least try to make another record that
could spend 13 weeks out at number one
you know what I mean like that was a
really rare situation because it was on
the soundtrack and it was dedicated to
the point you know what I mean but you
know if I when I go on YouTube and I
look at my top 3 you know I'm saying
songs they're all soundtracks and it's
all music that I wouldn't normally do it
on my own
so I have to do big songs that reach
other people to stay this global
phenomenon as well as bust [ __ ] ass
like you know with whatever concept
rather my favorite and I shout out I
give a lot of credits in my production
you know me I do last shot every patron
you know really Ricky Cardo like a
people Harry fraud Oh [ __ ] Benny
Blanco like these are people that I
trust and that kind of just like give me
[ __ ] Thundercat I've been I've been
working with him for years
we got like 20 some songs these are
people that if I need a certain sound or
if I'm in a certain mood I could go
straight to these dudes and they'll be
able to hook me up and I'll be able to
you know fully be myself hello well go
get the app man with anything else want
to say if we get about here brother yeah
go get the app Wiz Khalifa's we for me
I'm playing it right now just cashing
out go download it with real 92.3 it's
the real after-party yeah
[Music]